Demario Jackson opens up in his first
sit-down interview following the
bachelor in paradise scandal it was very
difficult 30 year old reality star got
emotional talking to E news one week
after Warner Brothers cleared all
contestants of any misconduct revealing
how the scandal involving him and fellow
contestant Corinne elympios has affected
him and his family was stressful for me
mostly for my mother it's hard to see
your mom might cry every single day that
was very difficult production halted on
season 4 after an alleged day of drunken
shenanigans including a naked pool
encounter between the co-stars led two
producers to file complaints
neither jackson nor elympios filed a
complaint but both hired lawyers my dad
he you know he kept me extremely strong
and kept me grounded and humble but
having your mom cry everyday like for
something that you know you didn't do
production on season four of the
bachelor in paradise has resumed in
Mexico but a source close to Jackson
told E t he will not be back on the show
this season
[Music]
you